hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt ich
habe heute ein rezept vorbereitet
welches ich schon auf der kunstmesse
zubereitet habe und zwar gibt es
türkische hörnle
es klingt leicht schwäbischem anhören
das sagt vielleicht sagt man er manchen
oder hühnchen der türkisch natürlich und
zwar habe ich die gefüllt mit einer
hackfleisch füllung natürlich könnt ihr
auch jede andere füllung nehmen das ist
jetzt aber unsere lieblings füllung vor
allem mathematik ganz gerne und der
hefeteig ist richtig genial den den
bereitet man zu und dann kann man gleich
weiterverarbeiten als er muss vorher
nicht aufgehen und deswegen ist auch
dieses rezept ziemlich schnell
ich zeige euch jetzt zu fn man die
zutaten für die füllung denn die bereite
ich zuerst zu und danach kommt dann der
hefeteig für die füllung traurig zwei
esslöffel olivenöl 250 gramm hackfleisch
ich habe die rinder hackfleisch eine
zwiebel 1 knoblauchzehe 150 com
schafskäse 50 milliliter wasser zwei
esslöffel tomatenmark pfeffer salz und
einen halben teelöffel currypulver den
harten themen paprikapulver jeweils
einen teelöffel minder und oregano und
100 gramm blattspinat ich nehme zuerst
das hackfleisch und die zwei esslöffel
olivenöl die kommen nämlich direkt in
die pfanne
da wird es hackfleisch schön angebraten
in der zwischenzeit kann ich schon mal
kaffee und zwiebeln fein würfeln
jetzt kommen die zwiebel und knoblauch
würfel mit dazu und werden so etwa 23
minuten mit gebraten
jetzt kommen auch das tomatenmark mit
dazu und wird auch ganz kurz mit
angebraten
jetzt wird das ganze mit wasser
abgelöscht und dann kommt auch direkt
der spinat mit dazu da fällt dann
natürlich gleich in sich zusammen
unser baby spinat rufen jetzt nicht
klein schneiden aber wenn ihr diesen
großen blattspinat habt dann könnt ihr
ihn gerne vorahnung etwas verteilen
jetzt an der stelle auch direkt würzen
mit salz welche bisschen vorsichtiger
denn der schafft da kommt er gleich noch
mit dazu und eben auch recht zahlt sich
deswegen würde ich es als erste zu geben
wenn der schafskäse später mit
sobald der spinat darm zusammengefallen
ist ist die füllung auch schon fast
fertig schalten den herd auf lasst sie
bisschen abkühlen und den schafskäse
gebe ich danach dann erst dazu
und jetzt kann ich in der zwischenzeit
schon mal den hefeteig vorbereiten
für den hefeteig brauche ich 250
milliliter milch inhalten glöckl hefe
einen halben teelöffel zucker 20
milliliter warmes wasser einen teelöffel
salz 100 milliliter olivenöl 1 ein
päckchen backpulver und 500 gramm nehmen
ihr könnt natürlich jetzt sonnenblumenöl
oder olivenöl nehmen olivenöl schmeckt
etwas stärker unsere blumen schmeckt
einfach geschmacksneutralen ich nehme
jetzt zuerst und hefe und das wasser die
hefe löst sich im wasser
und da kommt auch der zucker mit dazu
dann wird es kurz verrührt
als nächstes gebe ich jetzt das mehl in
eine rührschüssel den teig könnte jetzt
natürlich auch mit der hand verkneten
ich mache es gerne in der küchenmaschine
da geht etwas schneller bringt die
arbeit mit mir hat abgenommen
kommt da das was von vornherein schon
ruhig da einmal kurz durch
kann da direkt die milch mit dazu und
auch die restlichen zutaten bis auf das
öl das gebe ich immer gerne zuletzt mit
dazu und das eiweiß was ich jetzt noch
übrig hat vom igh gibt es kann ich
später noch benutzen um die hörnchen
dann zu bestreichen und jetzt den teig
gut durchkneten so etwa 15 minuten
gerne auch länger und sobald er ein
bisschen pathetisch es kommt auch das öl
betreiben
der teig ist fertig wenn er sich vom
schlüssel randow ist und nicht mehr
klebt der teig bleibt jetzt hier ganz
kurz liegen dies mache es nämlich zuerst
die füllung noch fertig und zwar ist
jetzt schon abgekühlt und jetzt kommt
der schafskäse mit rein
wir können den schafskäse natürlich auch
weglassen die füllung ist auch so schon
richtig genial
nun müsst ihr dann noch etwas salz
zufügen jetzt nämlich vom teig immer so
kleine runde kugel die kugeln könnt ihr
natürlich so groß machen wie ihr möchtet
ich habe die jetzt 25 gramm schwer dann
werden sie so richtig schöne süße kleine
körnchen die sind auch dann sehr
handlich wenn ihr sie größer macht dann
müssen sie natürlich auch etwas länger
back
die teig kuppeln werden dann opel
ausgerollt da wird braucht man
normalerweise kein mehl oder nur ganz
wenig mehl den datei klebt ihr nicht da
oben kommt dann in die eine hälfte ein
teelöffel von der füllung oder auch ein
bisschen mehr
jetzt glaub ich das hier oben zu bis zur
hälfte und drückt die ränder schön fest
damit die füllung jetzt auch beim backen
nicht herausfällt oder nicht raus läuft
und hier unten wird der teig
eingeschnitten und das ganze dann eng
aufgerollt und zu einem fernsehen
gefordert
die fertigen halten werden jetzt mit dem
eiweiss bestrichen dass man sich vorher
ganz kurz verkehren
ich mache es so immer ganz gerne so habe
ich nämlich keine reste und ich brauche
nicht noch mal ein volles sondern habt
das eigelb mit dem zeigt uns kommt dann
eben oben drauf und es gibt dann später
nun richtig schönen glanz
wer möchte kann die hören gerne noch
bestreuen zum beispiel mit schwarzkümmel
oder mit saison
ich glaube draußen geht die welt unter
essstörungen ziemlich und gewittert aber
ich mache weiter
mir scheint die sonne die hörnchen werde
in den vorgeheizten backofen weil 210
grad ober unterhitze für ungefähr 15 bis
20 minuten gebacken
ich nehme sie auf jeden fall heraus wenn
sie schöne frauen sind die hand in sind
jetzt gefragt aber auch eine richtig
schöne goldbraune farbe und ich habe sie
ganz kurz abkühlen lassen damit er hat
sich einfach nicht verbrennt gemacht das
war nicht so schön jetzt zwar nur so
oder so irgendwelchen gemacht und das
ding rein gemacht
das hackfleisch aber das ist für mich
richtig das ist schon richtig heimat
also im schwarm wendel
jetzt probieren apotheken im ofen
richtig gut auf und sind wirklich sehr
locker dadurch dass ich eben hefe und
backpulver mit dabei habe jeder gefragt
ist zu wenig hackfleisch rein das ist
genau richtig lag und ganz ganz tolle
teelöffel also ich wahnsinnig schmeckt
wie schwer zu wenig füllung drin steckt
man schmeckt mal nur dieses brötchen
aber die füllung ist insbesondere möchte
auch meine vegetarisch alt und neu ich
bin nun als ich würde auf jeden fall
auch noch eine vegetarische alternative
machen denn ich finde die auch zum
beispiel mit zucchini richtig lecker
haben
ganz vergessen am besten reismann dazu
wirklich einen türkischen tee und diese
hörnchen könnt ihr zum beispiel auch mal
zum frühstück zubereiten oder bei uns in
der türkischen kultur gespart
schwäbische konnte da gibt es die
einfach mittags zum tee oder haben sven
mal gäste kommen also also ohne die es
diese noch besser als wenn eine mutter
will er aber auch dass der teig so
richtig schön ding ist wo ich sein
gleich gut
ich finde es gigantisch dankeschön
wirklich leid muss schnell machen denn
du musst jetzt auch samira vom ballett
abholen
ganz schlimm ist es nicht so viele weil
ich uns gleich ein foto machen heute
einen blog und falls sie dieses rezept
nach machen wollt könnt ihr gerne auch
auf meinem blog gehen auf cds - blog.de
da steht man ganz so ausdrücken dass den
zucker gebe ich dir auch gleich alles
mitmacht und jetzt war es so einfach
möglich glaubt so wohlers und lässt mich
hier alleine stehen also ich wünsche
euch jetzt noch ganz viel spaß beim
nachbacken und wir sehen uns dann nicht
ein schönes macht's gut schatz bereits
richtig mag es für unterwegs
die hosentasche natürlich ein praktisch
genau die größe mit kümmel
handelspartner moretti